speaking of things that are horrible
sorry but Antonio Brown has been
somewhat horrible over the past few days
fired by the Patriots on Friday as of
Saturday three teams were interested
pending the outcome of the NFL's
investigation as of Sunday tweet storm
goes after Robert Kraft goes after Big
Ben says he's done playing in the NFL
went after Robert Clem Co the guy from
si.com had the story last week that
really was that last domino that last
push that a few days later
Antonio's fired by the Patriots you know
I knew he wasn't gonna stay on the high
road for long and I think anybody who's
thinking about signing Antonio Brown is
watching what he's doing but still
people are gonna be seduced by the
talent I think that at some point once
he unless he's banished for life which
could happen if the NFL decides that
Britney Taylor is telling an accurate
and truthful story about being forcibly
raped by Antonio Brown I think he's
banished for life but something short of
that a suspension ten games
eight games six games whatever I you
know I'm surprised somebody hasn't
signed him to a contract just to secure
dibs on him for whenever he's clear like
Washington did last year when they
claimed Ruben Foster on waivers knowing
at some point we're gonna get the
benefit of this yeah okay yeah well it
wasn't a good look for the Redskins at
that point and I think with Antonio
Brown right now you got to be scared
like what else is going to come out
right I mean I think that's the big
thing I just can't imagine anybody would
be crazy enough to sign him until some
of this stuff gets settled right Mike I
mean to me that just would be insane I
mean I would I would really argue if
you're crazier than Antonio Brown if you
sign Antonio Brown right now I mean I
just don't even understand how that
could be a thought you got to let this
whole thing flush itself out figure out
where it stands with the NFL you know
with law officials whatever it may be
but I wouldn't watch Aniyah Brown right
that's the thing there's no but they
interviewed Brittany Taylor last week
for ten hours and like it's impossible
to keep this stuff completely quiet
maybe there's some chatter making the
rounds and she's telling a persuasive
story or or not but but but here's the
thing I keep coming back to and we see
it in the impulsive behavior of Antonio
Brown
when it's time for him to sit across
from a table and be interrogated by
someone from the list yeah I hear you
Mike he is going to snap at some the
emotions it's not gonna be a good
witness he's gonna be Colonel Nathan
Jessup you know who that is
absolutely not a few good men right
technical the code Road at some point
Antonio Brown is going to snap on
whoever is asking him questions and and
it's it's unfortunate I've seen this
when I was practicing law you can have
people who are extremely good liars very
persuasive hmm you can also have people
who are horrible truth tellers and
Antonio Brown may be completely innocent
but because of how he is because of how
he's wired he is not going to be able to
sit there and submit right right did all
of this flows from and I know that that
you've defended my Tallman but Mike
Talman enabled this guy Mike Talman
created this guy by letting him get what
he wanted over and over again and I'm on
record last week saying when you have a
great player you got to do what it takes
to make him happy yeah this is what
happens when you take it to the extreme
yeah right because he's never heard no
he's never been made accountable the
most accountable anyone ever made him
was the Patriots firing him on Friday
night because the first time he was
fired by a team this year and he didn't
want to be right so this is gonna be
tough for him and when it's time for him
to talk to the league I think it's gonna
go sideways and who knows what the
league's all-time gonna decide and like
I said if they decide he raped Brittany
Taylor and I think the only appropriate
outcome is to ban him for life yeah I
mean I I'm with you there I mean if that
that's what happened and that's the
allegation yeah I mean if they decide
that she's telling the truth right even
without a criminal charge right if they
decide we talked to her we talked to him
we ran down the other evidence and we
think she's telling the truth
he's done out of the fact that they've
seen his text this past weekend of him
bullying you know another person who of
course just added more fuel to the fire
so I would think so too
if they feel that that he did do that
that he would be in deep trouble of
never playing ever again
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports